the Audrey updo is Winter's favorite
throwback hairstyle taking its name from
Audrey headb bur's most iconic hair do
the style is inspired by the look that
Audrey wore as Holly Go Lightly at
Breakfast at Tiffany's it falls
somewhere between a French twist a
beehive and a shinon and while it
inspired a generation of women at the
time it's back and it's doing the same
thing again it's more Prim than the
lowkey styles that we've seen in the
last decade but we've noticed people
want to look a little more Glam while
upd like Pamela Anderson's famous
hairstyle have been trending the Audy
rendition is a little more polished the
ends are kept tuck in and leans into
that old money RS aesthetic that's been
taking off on Tik Tok instead of a
dynasty you'll only need some bobby pins
for this one we've seen it worn Compact
and cute soft and romantic with a '90s
Twist pretty and Polished big and bold
and soft and swirled